this is extremely important to me and to
my wife from my wife being a native
nevadan of asian descent her parents
immigrated
from china her dad was the first dealer
on fremont street chinese uh dealer
which we're really really proud of and
this community needs to know that we
support them
in its entirety i mean these businesses
deserve our support
these people deserve our support and the
hate and the discrimination needs to
stop
and as a state i'm proud of the
diversity we have
we need to do everything we can to make
sure that everyone feels safe sure and
we're seeing an uptick in
this racism and hate against the asian
community across the united states
what's your message to the community
here in las vegas about denouncing
this racism well they need to denounce
racism and i think you see that on all
the sides here you know stop racism uh
stop the violence end violence
love conquers hate you those sort of
things and it's important that they know
that there's someone they can turn to
unfortunately this community
for a couple reasons one the language
barrier they don't often report things
so a lot of crimes against the community
go unreported and two that they just
kind of don't want to
go rock the vote but they need to they
help the need to make us aware
they've got our support you saw
congresswoman titus here with us
metro's supporting us so we're doing
everything to make sure that everyone in
this community is in everyone in nevada
feel safe thanks a lot appreciate thank
you
thank you thank you so much
having the first lady of our state out
here is a huge impact on this community
can you tell us
some of the words that you said up there
out here
yeah of course i represent as you know
i'm asian and i want to
bring awareness to asian issues and one
of the most
difficult issues is what we're talking
about today
we've seen so much going on across the
country
and we really want to prevent that and
so we want to bring support
and awareness to this very important
issue
and how important is it to have
everybody out here
to have the media so people can see that
the asian community in las vegas is
strong
well as you know it's critical it's
critical in order to bring awareness
we need media like yours to show up
and to really understand
what's happening with the asian
community after speaking with some of
the people here
what are you hearing from community
members well really they're just
you know they're kind of concerned of
course
as you know a lot of the hate crimes
don't
get reported and we want to make sure
that they're getting reported
and so that metro police and the
authorities understand what's going on
anything else you'd like to say about
coming out today and making your voice
heard
oh well it's an honor to be here to
represent the community and to make and
to create awareness
thank you so much